[Music]
what Tekken 7 Tekken 7 your review in
progress is up on GameSpot you want to
read more in-depth but your impression
so far my person so far is that Tekken
has have never been a series that
changes all that much and that's very
true with this one but that's not
necessarily a bad thing there's not that
many 3d fighting games on the market
like yeah a lot of games use 3d graphics
but they're fought on a 2d plane
so among the sort of like peers that it
does have Tekken just feels like
something totally different and it's
fighting system has you know kind of
been refined over the last 22 years and
it kind of feels like it always has but
again that's not really bad because it
really is a great fighting game so you
know it's moved to Unreal Engine 4 is
the first time it's on modern consoles
and MPC specifically PC and it looks
great the fighting is good to have a few
new mechanics the probably the most
important of those is this thing called
the oh crap I forgot the name there is
this move basically where as a move it
has a property where you have armor so
if I initiate a punch but you hit me
while I'm going to punch you I won't
stop like I would have in the past my
punch will continue okay so it's sort of
like a you know risk reward scenario
where you know you're going to take a
hit but you're gonna actually give a hit
as well someone's like a centimeter left
of health you could just get two quick
hits and to finish them well right as
long as you have the health to absorb
there yes yeah like right for yes but
you know the other part of checking
outside of the fighting is the
ridiculous characters and story this
game kind of continues that tradition of
you know telling hello
that is weird weird as as not us yeah so
yeah it's a weird story that a family of
martial artists who are constantly
trying to kill each other are constantly
coming back to life as demons and
there's all these like different
corporations involved it doesn't it
doesn't really make sense it's very
difficult to follow but that's kind of
it's made that way there's a lot of
comedic stuff as well a lot of secondary
characters are not really a part of the
main store
they're treated as jokes so you get this
really nice mix of like self-serious by
kind of kidding stuff and then outright
comedy paired with a fighting game
that's very technical but pretty
accessible I think do you like the
characters in terms of uh like their
actual moves that's fighting there yes
like a good variety yeah so the last
game I want to say there were 44
characters that has been whittled down a
little bit I think there's somewhere
like 32 now okay but that means there's
less copies you don't have as many
characters that seem like you know just
another version of another character
it's good but you know they they all
kind of fight so close together that
it's not real until you play these
characters that you really begin to feel
their their differences I will say Akuma
is now here from Street Fighter and he
plays very naturally if you've played
true fighter before you know how to play
Akuma you can pretty much jump right in
and pull off the moves that you want to
but of course you have to compete with
them a little bit differently as well
it's not the same as playing in a Street
Fighter game in terms of competition
right so Tekken its control conceit is
that it you know like each button is
mapped to a limb correct record since
Tekken 1 yes which is why I consider
this can be pretty accessible because
you know unlike a game like Street
Fighter where you're not really sure
like I mean you know what punches and
kicks are but here you really have this
direct relationship between this is my
left arm this is my right arm and that
can help the thing is that this game has
so much death and it does absolutely
nothing to really guide you
characters have moved lists that are
upwards of like a hundred moves and
combos that are not broken down by
category in any way you literally have
to just scroll through them which you
can do by looking at the list or going
into training mode and like cycling
through one move after another it's a
long process you know like any fighting
game to become really good in this one
but it's flashy enough and it's
accessible enough that most people can
jump right in as long as their
competition is on the same level as them
have a good time you mentioned it's
accessible in terms of controls and
everything looking back at injustice to
another recent fighting game that you
reviewed yourself as well and gave a
nine out of ten would you say that this
game is using that accessibility to kind
of like you said it's it is introducing
maybe new people to this universe but
also kind of not without sacrificing the
depth of the Tekken
I think the accessibility here is almost
consequential I think injustice to you
know another realms games in general
like they try to be accessible upfront I
think just you know what Tekken is is
just inherently accessible I don't think
they're going out of their way because
again there's no real training right
it's I mean just the literal controls
are easy to wrap your head around sure
not the actual movesets of the
characters okay as you get farther into
this review I was like I was online
going right now have you tried much yet
I've only had a few matches with people
in Europe and it's been spotty
connections so I can't say which is why
I'm kind of holding off on the review
this game will live and die by its
online component okay
um checking her Tekken Tag Tournament 2
was the last in the franchise that was
2000 I want to say 14 14 and then Tekken
6 was when 2008 Randolph reigns you
reviewed that one [ __ ]
he's our editor-in-chief now hey she
said that was such like anger did he
give it a score he's a review many games
um
um gave it a 8.5 okay Tekken Tekken
games always score very well because you
know they're always great and they don't
need to change a lot and they never
really do what did we give pokken poking
got a 9 oh yes and that was from
tomorrow zine
so uh in your early hours or I guess
you're pretty far in now but in your
time you spent playing now it was worth
the wait since the last Tekken games
yeah honestly I guy you saw me on the
lobby you know the weeks leading up to
this I kept like randomly saying like
also Tekken 7 is coming out like this
series is very nostalgic for me like it
is you know when I think about what it
was like to own a Playstation when those
first came out
Tekken and like Ridge Racer like these
Namco Games like really defined what it
was to be a PlayStation owner so it's a
very special thing for me and I just
love the way that this fighting system
works the characters are just so batshit
ridiculous too it just it makes it fun
and there's a lot of collectible items
that you can get to customize your
characters so you can make a serious
jerk like Brian look like you know it
give him butterfly wings and pink pant I
mean you can just you can go all out you
can have a lot of fun screwing around
these characters there are no stats like
there are
justise that's just aesthetics right
right yes some of the items you equip
like in Tekken Tag 2 and I'm not sure
about Tekken 6 but some of the items you
equip can be used as weapons so like I
have a guy with a pizza on his back that
he can throw across the ring nice Pete's
pockets yeah like I told you this game
is ridiculous
why didn't you believe me Rob's gonna go
down that's right now I love ya but yeah
I mean those things you know you're
risky you're putting yourself at risk to
use them because there's a very long
wind-up but you know they can change a
character who doesn't have a projectile
oh yeah have you ever thrown a pizza in
real life dude that's not something you
could just sling off the wrist you gotta
get ready for it depends on the crust
I think yes thank you whether it's yeah
New York or Chicago dude if you throw a
deep-dish pizza someone they're not
getting back up for a while
you guys watch did you get the chance to
watch the stream we did of this last
week that was the the weird double lobby
set for anybody wondering we had what
mr. knab's was that Richards leaf for
Richard Lee's first time on camera for
GameSpot so Richard Lee is one of our
more prolific fighting game players here
in the office but he's also always
behind a camera like maybe 80% of the
time if there's a video with like camera
work it's Richard Lee but it was fun to
see him on a stream but like I said he's
also a big fighting game player and we
had i'm so sorry the name of the player
escapes mr. naps
mr. naps thank you very much you just
said that um the stream was pretty funny
because at one point he was using one
hand to fight like Ben and Tay and
people right at the beginning of the
year oh yeah so he was playing with one
hand but also he's playing with his left
hand so movement and buttons like he had
to like completely take his hand off of
the joystick yeah he was on the right
side right yeah I was so cool to watch
and uh like chassis is a huge Tekken fan
and she would always when we both were
to die GN together she would always like
sweep tournaments so it's just really
funny to watch them like be like how is
he beating us with one hand so
definitely check that out
yeah it's archived you can go watch that
on our YouTube and twitch channel or
sorry uh yeah YouTube and twitch and
GameSpot do you have any D either you
have interests in Tekken 7 uh not quite
when you said pizza man you had me at
pizza um I want to try it out for sure
you
yeah it's like something I feel like
people should at least play the brief
little character stories just to to get
a sense of it because it looks like such
a self serious game you wouldn't believe
how funny it can be if you just dig into
it it's actually not that hard to find
that stuff one of the other cool things
is it has every cutscene from every
Tekken game ever made in it what yeah
which is pretty rad in their original
graphics or like yeah I did know there
was a question so and actually in the
story mode it'll put like if a character
is thinking back to a time it'll cut to
like a large incredible it doesn't take
itself too seriously despite appearances
yeah I think Tech is wonderful it's it's
one of those games that kind of gets
lost behind the noise of something like
injustice and Street Fighter um but I'm
glad to see that it's still kickin I
know I've already kind of recommended a
few videos and articles on GameSpot but
I think was last year two more Hussain
in the UK interviewed Harada
oh yeah that's probably worth checking
out it being brought as a character to
more as a character together yeah uh for
those who don't know who Hirata is
Katsuhiro Harada is sort of the lead of
the Tekken series and yeah he's a he's
an interesting guy
always the sunglasses always house
always has someone always has an opinion
yeah he was at a last year's Pokemon
World Championship no I think was in
Boston he was in the which was two years
ago um just like I saw him from a
distance of the sunglasses on he's like
surrounded by women and it was awesome
yeah look there he is it's alright
that's how you know it's Hirata
yeah man the women in the sunglass the
pantheon of doors and yeah he was there
for pokken I should have yeah so yeah so
yeah team Tekken helped develop oaken
this yeah yeah um to review you have a
tentative time frame next week sometime
I mean yeah we gotta get the server's to
go live and it's not just about one of
you one matches there are these like
small tournaments they've cooked up
there's a lot of things need to test so
in a perfect world I'll have a review
ready Saturday I have a feeling it's
going to be in a day Monday so I can
play this weekend cool
[Music]